[Musik]
sebastian lege lüfte das geheimnis
pflanzenfett und
das nicht zu wenig er zeigt wie der keks
mit günstigen zutaten und perfekte
marketing zum beliebtesten klicks der
welt wurde
herzlich willkommen in meinem urio
kreativ labor wir machen jetzt mal
designer oreo kekse der erfolgreichste
keks der welt besteht wirklich nur aus
mehl
zucker
glukose sirup
ein bisschen backmittel
ein bisschen öl
kokosfett
bisher letzte team das das luftige vom
keks auch erhalten bleibt und ganz
wichtig ja vanille aroma
[Musik]
dann butter aroma noch dazu
jetzt wird's bunt
in diesem tag steckt garantiert nichts
frisches bringen egal was auf der
packung steht der geschmack kommt von
zugesetzte aromen farbstoffe sorgen für
die passende optik
[Musik]
denn oreo kekse gibt es schon lange
nicht mehr nur in schwarz
backen ist so schön das ausrollen
ich noch mal so viel spaß
produktentwickler sebastian liege sehnt
sich nach den maschinen der industrie
für seinen nachgebauten oreo kekse muss
er jeden arbeitsschritt per hand machen
14 minuten kommen die kekse in den ofen
bei 180 grad
[Musik]
aber was macht diesen schoko keks mit
gram füllung so beliebt dass menschen
auf der ganzen welt verrückt danach sind
[Musik]
zuerst drehst du in
orio werbung setzt wieder auf geschmack
noch gesundheit sondern auf die art wie
er gegessen werden soll ja sehr dunkel
mit logo
dann sollte hier ein getunkt werden
ich verstehe immer noch nicht warum das
ist ein ami dingen oder
[Musik]
das verstehst
der lust sich komplett auf
zuckersüß und kunterbunt neben dem
original bietet model s den keks in ganz
vielen geschmacksrichtungen an
auch coco die so monika
klein war die nina sonne
geht es um fertig
nur solange der teig warm ist ist er
noch weit genug und die kekse mit ihrem
berühmten muster auszustechen
[Musik]
diese verflixte orio vorn unsere form
ist eine stand vorm in der fabrik ist es
eine walzen form der teig wird in einer
endlos rolle ausgerollt und die walze
väter drüber dann hat das eine kleine
verzahnung und dadurch dass es eine
walze ist geht das gleichmäßig im rein
und raus rein und raus und
dementsprechend haben die ein perfektes
muster
was man meiner konstruktion nicht so
ganz funktioniert hat das filigrane
muster der oreo kekse ist per an
schwerer herzustellen als gedacht
sebastian läge es nach bauten müssen
deshalb ohne auskommen
den selbst gemachten oreo keksen fehlt
jetzt noch die milchig weiße füllung
was sollen wir diese weise geben sagen
who
mit toller milch füllung
creme füllung
da sich ein tropfen milch drin und
trotzdem hat man die lese es geschafft
dass milch und orio im kopf der
verbraucher zusammengehören obwohl sie
nicht das geringste miteinander zu tun
haben ja diese wunderbare weise cremige
füllung und jeder darauf abfährt
pflanzenfett und
das nicht zu wenig gut aufgeschlagen
wir wollen ja luft und volumen luft
kaum zu glauben die creme nach der die
ganze welt verrückt ist besteht vor
allem aus pet und zucker
das muss richtig schön fein sein damit
das fett in zucker sofort schluckt und
wie eine homogene masse bekommen jetzt
vanille aroma das reicht prise salz
in unserer parat
frühjahr steckte in der creme
tatsächlich mal echte milch bis
produktentwickler von model ist die
rezeptur änderten seitdem sind die kekse
noch günstiger herzustellen
das oro geheimnis
keine milch
viel fett zucker und leckeres vanilla
romario setzt weltweit auf vielfalt den
geschmack der weißen creme verändert
mandl es mithilfe von aromen
auch den keks gibt es in wechselnder
optik orio setzt auf farbstoffe um die
kekse in bunten varianten auf den markt
zu bringen
ich finde es schick zwar ohne muster
aber
geschmacklich ein zur apa
wissen sie was passiert
wenn man
meint keks designer sein zu müssen
[Musik]
ein bisschen verwogen
sebastian lege hat dann doch zuviel
farbstoff in den teig gemischt sein
nachbau gleicht ansonsten dem original
[Musik]
oreo kekse werden aus billigsten zutaten
hergestellt fett zucker farb- und
aromastoffe
milch wird schon lange nicht mehr
verwendet auch wenn die verpackung dies
durchaus nahe legt
stattdessen investiert model s viel geld
in das marketing für seinen keks
weltweit setzen spots auf den spaß beim
essen wenn sie interessante geschichten
schon selbst erfinden oder dastehen als
unternehmen wie man ein keks zu sich
nehmen die mädchen das zum teil
verbraucher machen das nach einer flut
neuer geschichte das heißt sie haben
eine geschafft eine interaktion mit den
verbrauchern hinzubekommen weil die den
krieg so toll finden und das sind ihre
extrem loyalen fans
und einblick zu youtube zeigt trio
beherrscht seine fans wie nur wenige
andere marken überall auf der welt
investieren menschen ihre freizeit um
videos zu produzieren in denen es
irgendwie um urio geht zur belohnung
gibt es klicks und likes von anderen
fans
damit der fangemeinde die
gesprächsthemen niemals ausgehen sextro
rio auf streng limitierte
sondereditionen
die game of thrones edition natürlich in
schwarz oder deutlich bunter die lady
gaga edition oder auch die nba dischen
immer sind sie nur für kurze zeit und in
begrenzter zahl erhältlich ist der
älteste marketingtrick der welt
verknappung von angebot das kommt sehr
gut rüber sehr begehrlich knapp aus
verbrauchersicht und damit ist die marke
orion tisch auch sehr stark wieder im
bewusstsein der verbraucher und es ein
ganz wichtiger grund warum wir eine
entsprechende marke kaufen in einem
supermarkt in düsseldorf möchte
sebastian lege herausfinden was
verbraucher von oreo keksen halten er
trifft sofort auf fans
euro klettern kennst du ja war ja sehr
bekannt sehr gerne in allen variationen
und in vielen formen also ich kaufe weil
meine tochter die liebt die tochter
liebt ja aber wie verrückten die
kreationen seien wir mal ein bisschen
bilderrätsel ich zeige jetzt mehrere
bilder von einem ganz beliebten produkt
und dann sagen sieben jahr welches davon
gibt es zu kaufen und welches habe ich
mir einfach mal so ausgedacht wie vera
die pina colada edition
ließe sich wirklich so ein oreo kekse
verkaufen
den fand die super dem thema an die
super klingt sehr fruchtig kann ich mir
sehr gut vorstellen tatsächlich könnte
so eine sonderedition war
und was ist mit dieser sorte honig
mandeln würde ich sage ja ja und
wie sieht's aus mit schwarzwälder kirsch
klingt sehr verlockend mit kirchen sehr
gut
ich hoffe die wirklich toll oder
sebastian liege kahn vorschlagen was er
wägt seine gäste lieben orio egal mit
welchem geschmack was macht diese oreo
kekse besonders also wenn ich meine
tochter beobachtet die nimmt den die
dreht den auseinander die elektra in
denen diese creme innen drin was auch
eine creme was meinen sie
keine ahnung
weltkriegs ist vegan ist reine ist ein
reines fett gemischt was ist 15 etwas
ddr palmfett wenn die das weiß dann ist
sie raus die luft immer schön hartes fed
vielleicht mal sagen ich habe da jemand
getroffen jetzt supermarkt der hat mir
was über dein lieblings keks erzählt
liebe grüße an die tochter ruby dass sie
mitgemacht habe gerne
und wenn euch unsere videos gefallen und
ihr nicht genug kriegen können von
unserem besser es sah dann gibt es hier
noch mehr videos und las amazon
abonnieren -button da ich würde mich
freuen bis bald